the founding fathers of this uh the
United States thought about human nature
and that's why there's a discussion
about the freedoms that are
necessary they really deeply deliberated
about that and I think the same could
possibly be done for AGI it is true that
history human history
shows that we tend towards
centralization or at least when we
achieve centralization a lot of bad
stuff happens when there's a
dictator a lot of dark bad things happen
the question is can AGI become that
dictator can AGI when develop become the
centralizer because of its power maybe
has the same because of the alignment of
humans perhaps the same Tendencies the
same uh Stalin like Tendencies to
centralize and manage centrally mhm the
allocation of resources and you can even
see that as an compelling argument on
the surface level well AGI is so much
smarter so much more efficient so much
better at allocating resources why don't
we Outsource it to the
AGI and then eventually whatever forces
that uh corrupt the human mind with
power could do the same for AGI it would
just say well humans a dispensable we'll
get rid of them do the Jonathan Swift
Modest Proposal
from a few centuries ago I think the
1700s when he satirically
suggested that I think it's in Ireland
that the the children of poor people are
fed as food to the rich people and that
would be a good idea because it
decreases the amount of poor people and
gives extra income to the poor people so
it's on several accounts decreases the
amount of poor people therefore more
people become
rich uh of course it misses a
fundamental piece here that's hard to
put into a mathematical equation of the
basic value of human
life so all of that to say are you
concerned about AGI being the very
centralizer of power that you just
talked
about I do think that um right now
there's a bias toward
over a centralization of AI because of
uh compute density and centralization
centralization of data and how we're
training U models um I think over time
we're going to run out of data to scrape
over the internet and I think that well
actually I'm working on increasing the
compute density so that compute can be
everywhere and acquire information and
test hypothesis in the environment in a
distributed uh fashion I think that
fundamentally centralized cybernetic
control so having one intelligence that
is massive that you know fuses many
sensors and is trying to perceive the
world accurately predict it accurately
predict many many variables and control
it right enact its will upon the world I
think that's just never been the optimum
right like let's say you have uh a
company you know if you have a company I
don't know of 10,000 people that all
report to the CEO even if that CEO is an
AI I think it would struggle to fuse all
the information that is coming to it and
then predict the whole system and then
to enact its its will what has emerged
in nature and in corporations and all
sorts of systems is a notion of sort of
hierarchical cybernetic control right
you have uh you know in a company would
be you have like the individual
contributors they're self-interested and
and and uh they're trying to achieve
their their tasks and they they have a a
fine in terms of time and space if you
will control Loop and and field of
perception right um they have their
codebase let's say you're in a software
company they have their code base they
iterate it on it uh intraday right and
then the management maybe checks in it
has a wider scope it has let's say five
reports right and then it samples each
person's update once per week and then
you can go up the chain and you have
larger time scale and greater scope and
that seems to have emerged as sort of
the the optimal way to to control
systems and and really that's what
capitalism gives us right you have these
these hierarchies and you can even have
like parent companies and so on and so
that is far more fault tolerant in
Quantum Computing that's my feel they
came from we have a a concept of of this
fault tolerance and Quantum air
correction right Quantum air correction
is detecting a fault that came from
noise predicting how it's propagated
through the system and then correcting
it right so it's a cybernetic Loop and
it turns out that uh decoders uh that
are hierarchical and at each level the
hierarchy are local uh perform the best
by far and are far more fall tolerant
and the reason is if you have a
non-local decoder then you have one
fault at at this uh control node and the
whole system sort of crashes similarly
to if you have uh you know uh one CEO
that everybody reports to and that CEO
goes on vacation the whole company comes
to crawl right um and so to me I think
that yes we're seeing a tendency towards
centralization of AI but I think there's
going to be a correction over time where
intelligence is going to go closer to
the perception and we're going to we're
going to break up AI into um um smaller
subsystems that communicate with one
another and form a sort of meta uh
system so if you look at the hierarchies
there in the world today there's Nations
and those is all hierarchical but in
relation to each other nations are
anarchic so it's an
anarchy would you do you foresee a world
like this where there's not a over
what you call it centralized cybernetic
control centralized locus of control
yeah so like that's suboptimal you're
saying yeah so it would be always a
state of competition at the very top
level yeah just like you know in a
company you may have like uh two units
working on similar technology and
competing with one other and you you
prune the one that performs not as well
right and that's a sort of selection
process for a tree or a product gets
killed right and then a hole or gets
fired and that's this process of of
trying new things and and and shedding
old things that didn't work is this it's
what gives us adaptability and helps us
Converge on uh you know the Technologies
and things to do that are most good I
just hope there's not a failure mode
that's unique to AGI versus Humans
because you're describing human systems
mostly right now right I just hope
when there's a monopoly on AGI in one
company that we'll see the same thing we
see with humans which is another company
will spring up and start competing
effectively that's been the case so far
right we have open ey we have anthropic
now we have
xai uh you know we had Meta Even for
open source was and now we have mistol
right which is highly competitive and so
that's the beauty of capitalism you
don't have to trust any one party too
much cuz we're kind of always hedging
our bets at every level there's always
competition and that's the most um
beautiful thing to me at least is that
the whole system is always shifting and
always adapting and maintaining that
dynamism is how we avoid tyranny right M
making sure that um everyone has access
to to these tools to to these models and
can contribute to the research uh um
avoids a sort of neural tyranny where
very very few p PE people have control
over AI for the world and and use it to
oppress uh those around
them